[Music]
[Applause]
all right how does it feel to be a mom
of two well it's about two hours in
so far it's going good
Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson's
son's birth front and center on the
season 2 premiere of the Kardashians
it's such a beautiful thing it sure is
the former couple welcomed baby boy
through a surrogate in August the camera
is there to capture all the precious
moments we're ready to get a baby do we
have to pee no are you sure
Coco's big sis Kim was by her side of
course experienced in the surrogacy
process herself no so we're going
they're having the baby right now yeah
we're going right in oh my God yeah by
the looks of closed face she was
understandably stressing this Baby's
gonna fall out okay all right okay she
is yeah
ready and go famous before
[Music]
push and go push harder harder harder
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
but once the little one arrived the
reality star felt a big sense of relief
I am so grateful it's such a beautiful
gift that we're able to have ever since
December it's been this Dark Cloud
looming over me every single day I've
been feeling depressed and sad and now
that my son is here I get to move on and
I get to enjoy
it's almost like I get to close that
chapter and be done with this trauma and
put it behind me that drama Tristan's
latest cheating scandal where he
fathered a child with another woman when
he was still with Chloe and the anxiety
of the situation had Coco on the fence
about Tristan being at the hospital for
the baby's birth he's not going to be in
the delivery room if he is going to be
there he'll be in the other room yeah
but I don't know my advice would be
for the sake of the baby I think if it's
an option
you did it once
mad at Tristan same situation
ish you can do it again and have him
there you know you'll have that story
for your child
apparently big sis knows best because
Coco took Kim's advice and invited
Tristan to come by
you're so true
you can go through hell and high water
but you can still come out and have a
beautiful positive happy life baby's
name has yet to be announced but Coco
did give us a hint it is going to start
with a t i I mean that's really the only
names I've been looking at
for now baby boys monikers remaining a
secret no name Johnson over here
[Music]